into the program Hong Kong police have
used water cannons to disperse activists
protesting against the new security law
imposed on the territory by Beijing the
demonstrators had gathered in the
Causeway Bay shopping district where
police warned them that they might face
arrest and prosecution for displaying
pro-independence banners more than 30
arrests have been made
then a water cannon do drove up and
began dispersing the protesters the new
security law targets Succession
subversion and terrorism with
punishments of up to life in prison
ntw correspondent phoebe cog is standing
by for us in a mall in Hong Kong phoebe
what is the situation where you are
I'm standing outside a high-end shopping
mall in downtown Hong Kong just now when
we pass through the more are suddenly of
thousands of bright police officers
lined up the corner light and then stop
and search everyone inside the mall and
on the footbridge so just to give you a
sense of like how the law enforcement is
carried out today more than three or
four thousands of police officers are
deployed today to control the or to like
stop any kind of like public assemblies
and political kettle gatherings today as
they banned any kind of political
gatherings today and just now like just
like ordinary citizens shopping in the
mall today because there today is a
public holiday but they are
unaccountable search as well nobody was
arrested but this is the style and the
way of law enforcement today and
thinking about like the first arrest II
this is a similar kind of like strategy
that police simply stop and search many
people on the street so this is what we
observed on the first day of the
intimidation okay so it's not when you
walk so a lot of searches there but but
we have had reports that police have
already started detaining people under
the new legislation what more do we know
about those first initial arrests
the first arrestee was suspected of like
violating the national security law
because he processed a plaque of like
worth of hopeful independent slogans
written on it so police has already
issued like perfect warnings of like not
to incite this kind of play subversion
and secession and as we observed over
the last couple of hours like police
keep like warning people of like not not
to change any like slogans or like to
show any protest of play cards like it's
just similar to or what like in the past
like something about like Hong Kong
independence or something about liberate
Hong Kong so that would be something it
may be illegitimate right now under the
new law and and a few have mentioned in
report over thirty have been arrested
already some are accused of violating
the national security and some are like
suspected of participating in illegal
assemblies and protests have also been
banned how is the pro-democracy movement
reacting what should i despite the fact
that police has spent any kind of
anti-government protest on the
anniversary today which is not common
over the past of two decades
traditionally people are tens of
hundreds of millions hundreds of
thousands of people march on the street
but today we can we can hardly see any
like significant crowd on the street
because most of them are dispersed by
police but politicians and approach
Marcos eFRAG figures are still urging
people to defy ban and to rally on their
personal capacity but on the other hand
as we see yesterday some of the
prominent pro-democracy parties has
already disband and dismissed and we
have talked to some of the activism home
and they protect that some of them are
some of the ancestors they may turn
transform into another way of like
underground activism in the future as
it's the coarsest way to hide and
expected right now PB Kong in Hong Kong
thank you